you
here we go all right we got some
monsters in here just a little last
minute joins ultimate gamer and macro is
in there I have a first round against
Armand tan zuoren okay yeah we've played
already many times here challenge this
Knight he's strong I nearly missed that
my queen was attacked there interesting
going for d5 hmm I'll trade my
LightSquared Bishop off he's a bad man
let's do it right now
I'll give them up for a night
play on the h-file can I pull that off
um looks scary
I'm gonna do it challenge this night
take with the bishop oh boy my knight
knight on h3 and why'd I do that
can I do this I don't have to is pretty
strong now
I'll trade that definitely I have a good
night versus bad Bishop position stop
this and I should be able to break over
here here we go I'll pick up the a pawn
yeah
getting me pond and
get this phone working there's no great
pond breaks
Oh
now I have a time edge I could get this
guy going now push in and here there
be a time one or not he had a draw there
for a second what am i doing
holy cow
takes my breath away I tell you ah man
how to get rid of my bad bishop
light-square bishop was no good to me
okay regroup man regroup
what am I trying to say still trying to
recover from last game because I need a
breather
give me a breather man time off her
breather there should be a breather
button where's the breather button I
thought I thought chest now I was
playing in this tournament now he's
taking a breather
Oh
get out of there clean shoo shoo go away
oh man maybe they'll revisit this square
might as well try the second time right
never
yeah I had a freebie Queen freebie clean
and a freebie poem could have captured
the rook okay I still have control
that's the big thing here I got control
okay maybe now we can finally pick up a
pond Oh stake here the rook is pinned
and let's just scoot up scoot up oh okay
I'll grab a pond and play here Queen
trade stop in the hook I'll go pack man
I'll go pack man mode careful we only
have ten seconds
Green trade I'm covering their flight
square let's run with the pond keep
going going trade three seconds green
trade there we go then all
the trickiness look at the chicken as
there was not a non-slip back to
tournament all right I'm on page two I'm
all tangled up here with my
audio okay here we go here we go here we
go
9.3 c4 what's 97 about I'm going to find
out just go here I don't want to take
and open up this a door for the bishop
so they're crazy to take this pawn okay
how does this Knight get out
how does he ever do anything exciting c5
is a good mode maybe I should have
replied with the d5 a knight moon with
an attack against the Queen
just castle let's hang on to him a 3 B 4
is an idea and now just even to support
my knight let's still go here not hmm
just get it moving all right hunter the
completing development
[Music]
guess we'll just double up ah
such a bother okay a night here and here
pretty annoying oh my god my time you
gotta be kidding you got to be kidding
on the rook I should be jumping in here
why have I not done that and Queen here
and it's the ball game no let's go here
first and then try to make that Knight
move move Knight you know you want to
move
we got mate
geez where did my time go with that one
was I thinking about
I don't know I just don't know where my
time went with that one okay ultimate
have not played this guy before it's a
scary account scary account okay let's
see what we get
against the ultimate gamer I pick up my
life squared Bishop up care about him
Knight takes pawn look at the sneakiness
Oh try this next breakdown f4 let's do
it
[Music]
okay let's go here
peeing on these squares
who challenged that night
good piece gonna push yeah whoo how do I
make progress run in the corner this
really isn't the greatest way forward on
the and I get smashed let's try this
when I hop into c3 Bishop takes pawn
okay Queen you have a big task
oh my rook needs to help
oh boy uncle
uncle
I'm defending d1 I get some trades here
everything covered though Oh where's my
time oh no it's a scary time it's a very
scary time good job night you're just
barely doing the trick I just want to
get rid of that losing idea I need to
rely on a silly night now it's not going
to work it's not working
not even close
oh I'm so down on time
their Bishop on g2 was a beast and a
half
ah man he did it all at Bishop on g2
killer killer defender killer attacker
what was he not doing okay I'm trying to
win material okay yeah I could take
first I'm winning upon here though holy
cow the guy in first has 17 all right
Knight has to block and I could just
take them I'm winning a piece I don't
know here it seems like a square black
really wants so let's take it away grab
some space surrounding a fork got it and
they don't even get my knife back bishop
on c3 let's get this night doing
something else take away b4 and I guess
just here and push the pawn let's do it
and get the rip
the end ooh let's just push this guy I
guess we'll hang on to
Bishop's for a moment that night isn't
going to bother me no stalemates no
stalemate right here and then here I'll
do the trick
all right back to chairman where do we
stand page 2 I have 10 15 minutes left
111 in here holy cow
again alright he's throwing the
different he's going at the clean side
clean cut oh okay gotta pick up the pace
for sure
duh yeah skill pace and skill I guess
we'll go here first in here
all ready are we ready
some exchanges let's try four yeah one
Rokoff I can still down here see if they
take that pun why not why not okay
don't know if I'll be able to hold this
one I'm going to try now let's go here
see what kind of progress that can make
down upon but I have the better bishop
I want to keep the bishop behind maybe
that's a pawn I could target now let's
see
square give a check I can take this pawn
their King goes too far I'll step up
with the King can I get up on I got upon
now if anyone could win it's me ah
probably a draw yeah I'll accept a drawn
down a time okay boom well that's really
going to hurt for trying to get podium
lands but and the probably just the best
that I could do with that game
do I have to go for cheap Trick's I
might need to start going for some cheap
Trick's are they called for here maybe
maybe get just going to get forked
playing like that that's all that's
going to happen get rid of that guy
let's go here
then here good commentary good
commentary that's what you're here for
go here and then here I'm going to try
that
saying I'm going to try that
oh man
okay let's play d5 send the Queen back
all right going all in I get here can't
stop me I'm still going to jump in I get
the Jeep to the G file faster I think I
do
my Knights pretty sweet on that f5
square I got to say I'm loving a knight
nf5 I got to take here and I win some
material no I love seeing the Queen and
King on the same file
oh I'll still go here though give up the
exchange I know I should just kept it
simpler my knight can move and pick up
the Queen no matter where she goes I
love that I love that discovered check
doesn't matter where the Queen he goes
she's gone
pick your favorite where do you want to
go knight on a dark square moves in
attacks a dark square boom pins double
attack let's take care who my bishops
even there to cover now we sweep over
sneak in and then go here no matter what
boom back to tournament land
still on page 2 is 13 I see Queen
mastering 11th who's on first not me
somebody with 26 Armin guy played in
round 1 is having a good tournament all
right I need to get another game in
fours err where are the fours
I got no.4 is one for far too many far
too few for us all right here we go
throw that bad guy outside the punching
trades more trades we're going to shoo
him away and jump in here no we're not
I'm going to run it like this here
alright I'll take your bad Bishop I'm
going to fight for control this file
see how you deal with that hit the Queen
first and I'll even go and save the
bishop I like them okay backward
development I stun you to fly square
guess we have to go here and you're
going to superglue your knight in there
okay
I could break up these poems let's do it
take care put pressure on this guy I
need to flight square I need a flight
square I guess this is the flight square
my rook is having a blast over here let
me tell you a blast blockading this fun
not really got to take at this phone or
do I
hmm I think I have to do this and then
go here to update the office for me who
flipping around flipping around take
there I have to be flipped
I want to put I don't want them to be
able to pre move so easily I get there I
need a time burn my way oh not there no
you sneaky guy Oh where's the fire man
where's the fire eight minutes left I
got 14 ah man
a sneak artist ah sneak artist he nabbed
my rook before his time fell ah sneaky
guy man sneaky guy so slippery man so
slippery unbelievably slippery you're
exaggerating again okay let's put a pond
in the center how about you afraid to
put a pond in the center every once in a
while how about two two is better than
one you get a sacrifice here now you're
going to go there alright how can i oh
I'll take that night where's the bishop
moon with check there's none careful
careful I just did tactics shortly a
just a little little while ago there was
some fanciness like this fanciness I got
two pieces on this
are you going wow I wonder if I can move
a little slower
move a little slower
I got that covered two bishops two
bishops where's the mate where you going
King check let's go here set up a
discuss
that's not stalemate check out this one
there
back to Trent where am I at 19th with 16
oh I just want a four I forget what it's
like to get a four sixteen who's in
first 33 hmm I feel like I need to do
scholars mate stuff okay maybe we try
for a quick kingside kills they're
offering a draw not one of these guys
let's get some space on the queenside I
guess it's going to drift over here and
how about a queen let's see if they take
here all right now now we're breaking
stuff down we're taking here run pawns
do some damage push I'll just give
turn back
council let's just take him out push
not about Queen here night I'll still go
here why not
Oh give another check
keep going pawns take here and then get
my bishop on g5 got this covered stand
keep them in a pin for forever for
forever they can't move Zook swung they
got jugs langde my opponent just got
zugzwang watch out for stalemate careful
check check this is the only way to win
the only way to win gotta take with the
rook careful careful careful mate Zoggs
langde for 18 left at least I got as
uggs laying in there who knows what I'm
talking about
okay eighteen which fire come on
I dropped a piece against this guy last
time we played not on stream okay look
at going for these quick attacks what is
it what's the story here all right I'll
try this give up my bishop to damage
that structure yeah
stylist are you defending how you doing
it
mm huh okay take out v7 let's do it
I'll take care if the knight moves and
be controlling b8 I'll grab another pawn
up to have the bishop pair not anymore
though
the knight over here I guess I try 4-h 6
or not let's save that pond I know
Bishop here I'll take here ok they're
going to start pushing mm-hmm you're
going to start pushing
ichael in another pond or am i think we
bit rook to b8 it's going to bother me
kind of break this stuff up push here
applying this well get my king on this
square soon
Knight right here trade bishops
I want the night here Fisher trade try
it again let's see what they do
wonderful one more time one more try
we're getting here there we go
contest this file I had a fork with this
there we go it's still there grab the
rope grab the night and everybody is
happy should have grabbed this pawn
first Forks got them time is not an
issue
let's return here no stalemate to pick
up upon score touchdown Oh Stan Lance
they're down on time back to turn I got
a four I'm in 11th I'm just shooting for
page one forget about podium land
give me page 122 maybe I get fifth maybe
try berserk game
let's try berserk game berserk
finish this one off gotta play fast how
to play really fast some trades in nap
playing a good game against berserk
tactic oh man I win this be amazing
it'll be amazing yeah they're quick
they're quick
kill the night or not you don't want my
night I got some something to play with
though yeah let's try this
hmm I'm in big trouble
nine seconds can't do anything
Oh getting made it in a cool way okay
that's going to be it I figured I'd try
to maybe get a five there that wasn't
happening though shooting for 27 not
meant to be 22 finished in 12th still a
few seconds left page 212
Panthera got first he must have slipped
up then Armen 39 38 and 34 top three are
mint and Zairian second Gary Chapala
slurred and macro GM was in there I
think he'd withdrew and then maybe came
back in not sure 150 you know all right
good games Oh
you